I have no interest in imposing my
work-life balance on anybody else people
are emailing me and saying jeez man I
follow you for seven years I've heard
you talk about hustle from the day I met
you I didn't get it you're like really
working at a level that makes me feel
uncomfortable they're saying that is a
good thing and then there's other people
saying hey man cool and great great job
buddy you're gonna be a billionaire and
buy the Jets but your family's gonna
hate you and you're gonna regret this
and die lonely and so Lizzy and I have
our work-life balance we communicate
about it we grew up a certain way I
think that it's a common conversation
but I think it's kind of like raising
kids right I would never have the
audacity to tell somebody how to raise
their children because every individual
situation is different people aren't in
my bedroom they don't know what makes me
and my wife happy or me and my kids I'm
all in when I'm around a lot of people
who judge my work-life balance a lot of
people that are gonna tweet about this
podcast around this issue
when they're home they're looking at
their phone they're playing video games
they're not really in turn gauging
mentally with their spouse or their
children and so I don't think it's a
quantity game I think at the quality
game I also think that you're speaking
right now to a guy whose dad he didn't
even know until 14 years old because he
worked every minute and I have the
greatest relationship in the world with
my dad and I love him so much and I've
been massively fulfilled if either one
of us leave the earth tomorrow I will
feel phenomenal of the quality of our
relationship I get it you'll never get
back the moments when a hit is three and
they do the first this time the other
thing on the flip side you never get
back the moments in the 20s 30s and 40s
I mean I when my parents and I go on
vacation together like I go lay in their
bed until 2:00 in the morning right talk
to them and that comes out of having a
great relationship and that doesn't
happen for a lot of people who saw every
wiffle ball game and every dance recital
I have no interest in telling people how
to live their work-life balance I'm
thrilled for anybody to critique mine
because I understand I put myself so out
there so I deserve it I just want
everybody know the only people that I'm
going to respond to around this
conversation are the 11 people in my
most inner circle of my family who are
the people that I most care about around
this issue
you